THE 40-YEAR-OLD A BIG PART OF
THE OF
IT, COZENS, QUICK GOAL.
KNOCKED IN THE
END OF THE REILLY SMITH. ST YEA
2.16 GOALS A GAME, BEST
DOWN LOW AT THE TOP OF THE
TO HONOR REILLY THE STICK
OF H
THAT LOSES THE THE HANDLE THE
POWER PLAY.
SHOT BY DADONOV.
HE'S STILL H H
NICK ROY!
A POWER PLAY GOAL ECTING THAT B
YOU WATCH THE PUCK GO DOWN TO
THE DOORSTEP.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
BACK.
BUFFALO TRYING TO KOLESAR BACK
AFTER THE STOP. WAS A GOOD BACK
PASS BACK, RESCUED BY
THEODORE.
HIT THE POST.
BODY IN
A FACE OFF WITH TEN AND A HALF
TO GO.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST CHANCE SI
>> THAT TIME DEFENDED WELL BY
HAGG. DEFLECTED
RIGHT THERE FOR GO
IN THE SECOND PERIOD.
VEGAS LEADING 4-0.
HERE'S A GREAT CHANCE FOR THE 1
PLAY HERE AGAIN IN A MOMENT.
ALEX TUCH, SHOT DEFLECTED, OF T
ONE C OF WHAT THEY DO.
BUFFALO ALMOST HAD THEIR
SECOND PERIOD TO THE DELIGHT
OF THERE.
GETS IT UNDER THE STICK OF
ALEX TUCH, AND TUCH WAS ON NET.
SET
MIDDLE.
THERE'S THREE ON THE OUTSIDE FO
THE AWAY FOR TUCH, TWO OMPSON T
TAGE THOMPSON SPINS AND
TALKED ABOUT THE ADVERSITY
THEY'VE FACED THROUGHOUT THE AC
PUCK.
HERE'S HAYDEN TRYING